[Music]
based on the books you've been meaning
to read they got spun off into games
you've been meaning to finish comes a
series that's meant to be the next game
of Thrones but ended up more like the
next Xena Warrior Princess I ain't mad
at it The Witcher get ready for the most
watched Netflix show ever because the
chainsaw the count the views as you
enter a sprawling fantasy world that
seems pretty complicated on the surface
but boils down to a vaguely polish
tokine with swears when there's
something strange in your ball or woods
who you gonna call a Witcher you don't
scan me that's too bad
highly trained you killing machines who
every [ __ ] in the land wants to pick a
fight with for some reason ya mutant son
of a [ __ ] did not know about it yeah
I've always wanted to play with one
right along with the titular witcher
geralt as henry cavill mean bucks his
way through the continent searching for
the minimum number of syllables required
to carry a series
must have some review for me three words
or less his destiny will be tied to Siri
a baby Yoda with the power of scream Oh
Jennifer a girl who left the Hogwarts to
deep state made by ploy to go live by
her own rules
selling boner weed and tagging along is
the father's bar character who everyone
hates my name is julian alfred hi with a
song or two that everyone begrudgingly
admits is actually pretty good toss of
coin huh i guess even fantasy realms
have to deal with their own version of
John Mayer
oh that sucks watch the action drama and
complete lack of comedy unfold across a
typical episode where Carole comes
across a problem he doesn't want to get
involved in I want you to join my team
you know then totally gets involved in
it and then while Siri runs through some
woods boringly Jennifer's dress comes
off then we switch timelines only you
don't realize it since half the
characters don't age so just enjoy an
awesome sword fight
some cool magic sometimes I guess I'll
come univers boobs again and at the end
of the day it turns out man was the real
monster all along it's a formula I can
totally get my oh the next one's already
started so if you ever wanted a show to
put images in your head they would match
the phrase porcupine wedding sexy
hunchback or magical hysterectomy then
you are super weird like us and we
finally have a show to enjoy together
because at peak TV was all about 12-hour
movies you have to binge all at once to
appreciate then I welcome the return of
shows that can say tonight on Witcher
meet a bog monster who's also a
beautiful lady coming up after an
all-new Buffy only on UPN story silent
but deadly The Hunchback of Notre Dame
hey Siri my ballads bring another cone
to the bar
blood sugar X magic bass beheadings barf
boobs midsummer
we're boys
haha your child talking about coin how
much coin feel cakey more than you seem
to find coin pretty charming yourself I
have enough coin to rebuild our house
attempt side all the way your coin fled
with that coin by coin my coin coin
talking about destiny you don't believe
in destiny I have to find my destiny
it's your destiny yes Donita destiny
destiny can go and that song you finally
got out of your head
[Music]
[Applause]
and it's back the hair which project
okay you just buried a baby at low tide
barely an inch into the sand you might
as well just chuck them to the ocean if
you're not gonna put some elbow grease
into it time from once I'm the honest
voice guy and I approve this message
volleyball is just professional hot
potato
get over here on nom nom nom nom nom nom
Merry Christmas you filthy animal never
give up and good luck we'll find you